and finally new rule new year's
call for new departments here on real
time and we have something very special
for you tonight
as our loyal fans know after every
election season we prepare a
memorial package called farewell
douchebags
so we can
so we can bitter do a proper ado to the
conservative nut jobs who just got
drummed out of office
here's a little bit of our last
installment from two months ago
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
always a fan favorite i've been doing it
for all these years problem is
republicans
restock douche bags with the efficiency
of an amazon
warehouse they churn out new crazy like
the hallmark channel makes christmas
movies
so i thought it might be prudent moving
forward if we took a moment at the
beginning of the year to get to know the
up-and-comers
the douchebags to keep an eye on the
the new fresh-faced hate-for-profit
truth-bending opportunist that you'll be
cursing out for years to come
so sit back and enjoy our premiere
edition of
hello douchebags hello
hello douchebags for example there's a
new
opportunistic infection in the senate
named josh hawley
oh he's an up up-and-comer washington
insider says he's among 2021's most
punchable faces
handsome youthful and vigorous he's the
far rights jfk
with a little dash of kkk
and as the son of a wealthy banker and a
graduate of stanford yale in a
private prep school josh knows what he
hates most in this world
elites
loathsome and transparently ambitious
josh was the first senator to formally
choose trump's baseless election fraud
conspiracy over his pledge to uphold the
constitution
but before you say he's anti-democratic
just wants you to know that he's just
asking questions questions like
why does the winner of an election
always have to be the guy who gets the
most votes
not to be outdone in the area of hating
government from the inside
freshman colorado rep and high school
dropout lauren bobert
is someone you may have already thought
of if you ever thought
what would happen if michelle bachmann
smoked bath salts
this sassy gal is taking her hoops out
to fight the libtards and she
and she wants everyone to know she has
exactly one issue
guns spoiler alert she likes them
she hails from a town named rifle and
owns a restaurant
called shooters where the wait staff
no kidding are encouraged to carry
loaded weapons on the job
my suggestion if you eat there make sure
you tip at least 20 percent
yeah i i ate there once i asked the
waiter how fresh is the fish
he said i don't know you feel lucky punk
alabama's newest senator is tommy
tuberville how to describe
tommy he's like if a hot mike slur got
voted into office
[Laughter]
love this guy tommy's the former coach
of the auburn tigers football team and
intellectually let's just say he's a few
yards short of a first down
he refused to debate before his primary
and general elections and it's a good
thing because
he could lose a game of tic-tac-toe with
saint bernard
tommy's the model of today's
constitutional conservative who has
absolutely no idea what's in the
constitution
he got wrong the answer to the question
what are the three branches of our
government
strippers can get this one i know i've
asked financially tommy's been involved
with at least three business associates
who've been convicted for financial
fraud said tommy
i'm not smart enough to understand all
the numbers
did i mention he wants to be on the
senate banking committee
and seen
now
now if fresh-faced is your thing get
ready to swipe right
on rising hate monger madison corthorn
from north carolina
one of the leaders of the stop the steel
fiasco who hyped the riot at the capitol
like it was the fire festival
and who at the tender age of 25 is the
youngest republican
ever elected to the house i've thrown up
scotch
older than this prick
you know every chad douchebag you see on
a jet ski on instagram
yeah he's a congressman now
and this one brags that he carries a gun
on the house floor
but not irresponsibly it's safely
secured in his paw patrol lunch box
and finally but certainly not least we
have the freshman congresswoman from
georgia
the true mayor of crazytown and
everyone's
favorite karen marjorie
marjorie taylor green the congresswoman
who makes most people say
how is she not a teacher from florida
who [ __ ] her students
i don't know but holy [ __ ] is this lady
crazy
she does not listen to lobbyists and
special interests
no she listens to microwaves and talking
dogs
she is an all-in q anon believer who
thinks science and reason are a
conspiracy to trick people into thinking
reagan saw a shining city on a hill this
chick sees spiders on her arms
move over aoc say hello to wtf
all right that's hello douchebags
you